what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness so
I'm just going to get right to the point
I don't have the best news for you guys
to start the show so when I started this
channel really what always motivated me
and drove me was the pursuit of truth
it's never been about money it's never
been about Fame I have just wanted to
know what is true in the world because
growing up in 2023 as a woman it's like
we're constantly lied to we're
constantly told things that are fake to
appease us we're given jobs we don't
deserve and when I found red pill
content it it was almost like it just
made sense of everything that was going
on like we live in this society that is
so confused and what really has driven
me and motivated me is the pursuit of
Truth Now the problem is when you get
closer to the truth and you start to
find what is true in the world people
get angry and there are consequences
That You Don't See coming and
unfortunately
yesterday out of the blue with no
warning we were demonetized for hate
speech now I don't know what hate speech
is I I think it's hard to differentiate
what speech is speech that hurts my
feelings or hurts that person's feelings
or offends that person so this was just
super random out of the blue zero
warning so unfortunately we were
demonetized and I I guess what I've
learned throughout this is really there
are very few platforms that actually
Advocate and want freedom of speech and
want to get to the truth um they would
just rather lie to women and men for a
lifetime right now we're trying to work
with YouTube we have appealed it and we
are praying to God that they remonetized
us but I just don't know what's going to
happen in the future so you know guys if
they can demonetize us in a day they can
also kick us off YouTube in a day so
make sure that you sign up for our email
list it's a Google form right now we're
trying to get a website up and running
this week so we have an alternative
media platform right now it's just a
Google form so please sign up for it and
also if you want to support the channel
consider getting some merch but enough
about that let's get to the topics of
the day we are still going to keep on
going with pearl daily and our regular
programming we are just hoping that we
can work something out with YouTube
where we are no longer demonetized so
our first story of the day is going to
be talking about what do men want and
what do women want so as I've said what
they really like to do is they like to
lie to us and they always want to tell
women that we are so special amazing and
awesome at all time it's called
gynocentrism and it's been going on for
a thousand years since chivalry you know
men used to bow down to Kings and now
they bow down to women in marriage and
when they propose you know it used to go
with the natural order of the world it
used to go men or it used to go God men
women children but now men submit to
women's Authority which as you guys know
I believe that causes evil in the world
so I wanted to talk about how the
feminist programming has infiltrated and
influenced relationship advice
relationship advice is always what the
women want it is never what the men want
so I'll give you guys an example I had a
poll asking how many times a month is
appropriate for a babysitter when does
it become negligent to the children and
much to my surprise over half of whole
respondent said that over one to two
times a month was negligent now take
that with a grain of salt believe it
don't believe it that that's your
prerogative but what it made me think
was about how often I hear that date
nights are important to a happy marriage
there was a woman named Lauren Chen that
had a tweet something along the lines of
you should continue to date each other
and that that is important to a happy
marriage and I had to think about it for
a second and I really thought I don't
think so now why why did I say this
because our marriage rates are terrible
now and we live Easier lives than ever
and go on more dates than ever yet if
date nights fixed it then you would
think that all these marriage problems
would just be solved just go on some
dates um anyway so not saying date
nights are a bad thing but my point is
that in general the female point of view
is generally what people harp on for
success in relationships communication
date nights and making time for each
other when you think of those three
things guys who wants that women we love
to communicate you think men wake up one
day and just say amazing I'm so excited
to communicate with my wife today no
it's a Heche to them date nights do you
think men in general are super excited
to take you out to dinner no they want
to go to like the football game or
something now I'm not saying those
things are bad I'm not saying they're
unimportant but generally they favor the
women and making time for each other
have you guys seen the Patrice O'Neal
clip where he says I want you there but
in the other room it's like it's like a
funny clip cuz men is hard for us to
love you and like you at the same time
it's just it is what it is men want to
be alone but we don't want to be by our
self be we want
you somewhere like in the dwelling just
not here like just like around the corn
in the vents you can sit in the vent I
don't care if you want to watch me in
the B on the roof anywhere but just not
in front of me that's generally how men
are they're
not you know this is not the top of the
list for men you know okay so things
that benefit the man are not typically
relationship success Keys it generally
indicates that the relationship centers
around what the women want generally
when I see couples make these assertions
that those are the keys to the
relationship it's typically because the
woman's in the guy's ear telling him all
the things that she wants so Trad cath
HQ says men want stability and
reliability give a woman what she wants
all the time and she becomes spoiled
divorce really should be banned I can't
say this often enough yes I totally
agree when women are spoiled and I think
Lauren said something along the line and
I'm paraphrasing right it's been a long
24 hours guys she said something along
the lines of you should try for weekly
and I'm thinking okay let me get this
straight you guys want traditional men
that not only not only protect and
provide for you and if he's paying the
bills he's probably working a lot he
probably has a hard job now he also has
to do date night I mean women respond
very Sim similarly to kids that are
spoiled women that get everything tend
to start calling themselves like
princesses they just start doing all
this weird stuff Dr Manhattan I wonder
why men are over it give give give and
she's bored she starts to take Brandy
burus says all modern relationships and
marriages are women centered I'll
probably encourage my son to have
children but not get married there's
nothing in it for the man but hell so
and this is the consensus now I'm not
happy about this consensus but but again
guys I want to know what is true in the
world I am searching figuring out why
people are so confused why can't people
get together that is my primary goal I
want to know what is true so if the
truth is that for most men marriage does
not benefit them I'm going to tell you
that regardless of how I want the world
to be because it's not about me and my
feelings it's about what is true have
you ever heard that the key to a happy
relationship is sex silence and sandwich
is no because typically relationships
are centered around what the women want
that's why you have all these chicks
freaking out over date nights they
reveal themselves it's about what she
wants so I want to point out guys when I
when I point out these patterns I'm not
talking about anyone in particular
sometimes I use someone's reaction as an
example but I don't know them personally
if the shoe doesn't fit don't get mad at
me we're just using examples that I see
and women that heart so heavily oh my
husband enjoys date
night they tend to not really be in tune
with what their husband wants and they
tend to have people please their
husbands husbands that will do anything
to make them happy there's nothing wrong
with it if the woman appreciates it but
typically in those relationships the
women do not run them and they have not
really spent the time to study men and
figure out what they actually want
because sex silence and
sandwiches sounds like a pretty good
deal to most men um you know so the
comment section really was a mix there
was a mix so just Bill said most men
learn happy wife happy life how that is
undertaken is up to you one thing I know
after 38 years of being married it takes
two people trying to make a marriage
work the next comment says the problem
is that women expect princess treatment
for simply existing yes and that's my
point why why do date nights need to be
a weekly thing how much how much do you
deserve in a marriage again this shows
the mindset in general of women because
they're focused on what they want
instead of what they can do for him and
so they'll say well marriages are
happier with date nights okay do you
think if you did a poll saying to men
are you happier when your wife gives you
a blow job every
day it would be like water is wet the
sky is blue but my point is it's always
focused on what the women want uh women
are generally Tak and will drain a
kind-hearted man of all joy and passion
and the women always they always get
triggered and again it shows more about
them than it does about me I swear it
does if your response to do men this is
my tweet do men wake up and think wow I
just wish I could have some more quality
time with my woman today no be real they
want sex silence in a sandwich is that
generally true or generally un true I'm
not talking about you guys' husband and
like the women have this need just to to
tell me their Saab story and their
personal story about oh but my
husband yes yes we understand there's
exceptions they don't make them the rule
and there's reasons we have phrases like
sex silence and a sandwich but
apparently because I said this I have a
deeply broken soul and I'm sad I am just
a sad hateful woman and I just thought
terrible and I respond I say it's
actually not sad that men like sex
silence and sandwiches the same way it
is not sad that women like date nights
neither of those things are sad but the
point is we should be focused on what
the other person wants and too many
times women think that the world
revolves around them and you can see
that they think that the world revolves
around them because whenever I ask a
general question they always make it
about them anyways all these things are
quite easy so we should be rejoicing I'm
giving you guys the keys I'm like guys
men are pretty
simple will says the sad thing is that
women commenting are just too slow to
understand what men want and they want
to be like we don't care about what men
want really Karen then why do you have
an opinion and that's my question these
women just sit on my tweets all day
commenting at me picking at me every day
and I think well why don't you go
somewhere else like what what why are
you
here if you're not interested in
learning about what men want why are you
here go somewhere else shark said no one
said that was sad though you aren't
addressing what people are saying people
think it's said that you don't believe
men want to spend quality time with
their wives no I think the quality time
is
different women's quality time is
talking date nights men's is sex silence
and a sandwich if you said all right
this is what we're doing tonight I'm not
g to talk we're gonna have sex and I'll
make you some food you think I mean I
think most guys would be like go amazing
I I don't think that's sad guys and we
need to stop getting so emotional and
triggered over what men want men want
what they want and you can either get
mad about it and die alone or you can
adapt guys like none of this stuff is
rocket science that's why I questioned
so many times why people get so angry at
my channel because the things I say are
basic they are so basic this used to be
taught from our grandmothers our mothers
and grandmothers but now you have a
bunch of older women that want to see
you fail that is what they want all they
want is for you to be miserable with
them how how many times have I shown you
guys a clip of a woman saying that her
friend led her to getting divorced
misery loves company and for whatever
reason women love to see other women
miserable midatlantic Madam a woman that
doesn't believe the home is another
Battlefield in the war against the
patriarch he gets this kind of attention
the others are avoided as much as
possible all right so the next thing
that I guess I triggered I I think I
triggered um this chick named Christine
mayor or something and her husband I
actually I went on her podcast a while
ago by the way it's not personal anyone
that's watched me for a while I cannot
pronounce names for the life of me I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry um anyway so I
said it's generally low testosterone men
that argue that they like date nights
just as much as their wives feminine
point of origin now do I know the
testosterone level of every male no okay
these are just general trends that I've
seen the same way that you see liberal
men generally have low testosterone
there are stud I that prove that I've
noticed that men that constantly argue
from the woman's point of view meaning
they argue for the exception not the
rule they'll say things the way women
say well you shouldn't say it like that
they tend to either have a domineering
mother that was very career oriented
that didn't spend a lot of time with
them and imposed her will and tried to
control the father second Trend I see
single mother home third Trend I see low
tea low testosterone this isn't an
insult to anyone personally it's just a
Trend that I see Shauna you make a false
claim men tell you overwhelmingly that
you're incorrect you then reply that
they must be something wrong with those
men maybe just maybe the issue is more
than the men who are telling you that
you're incorrect so funny thing is
that's not the general Trend my audience
is mostly men I the way I blew up in two
years was actually phenomenal and
unheard of you don't get almost two
million subscribers in a year and a half
two years without saying something that
is true and that's why I always say you
guys always want to shoot the messenger
don't shoot the messenger I'm asking you
what am I saying that's untrue do men
generally like sex silence and
sandwiches do men that constantly defend
women and have this gut reaction to De
defend women tend to have low
testosterone or from a single mother
home that's the tendency are there
exceptions obviously but here we talk
about generalities and the rule no it's
not just men that disagree with me that
tend to have low testosterone levels and
domineering mothers it's just a general
Trend I see it's the men that have a
feminine point of origin meaning that
they look at everything through the
female lens typically from single
motherhood or domineering mothers
exactly exactly you know and then I'll
see people get all triggered and mad and
I'm just like guys guys guys I'm not
talking about you if it doesn't apply
Let it Fly and we used to know this you
know I've heard men say they would never
date a social media influencer and I
could get mad and say ah ah but Pearl
Pearl does this for a living ah or I
could sit back and realize okay this
conversation is not about me is that
generally true or generally untrue and I
would argue generally true whether or
not I like that I've heard men say
things like I would disqualify women
over the age of 25 I'm over the age of
25 and I have to think generally are
women better or worse over 25 and
generally younger they're more pleasant
they're less damaged and they're better
to be around that's generally true
whether or not it applies to me doesn't
matter because my feelings about it
don't matter the truth matters that is
what matters and what I'm sick of seeing
is women shielding other women from the
truth because they don't like it because
it applies to them who cares if it
applies to you or not truth is truth
regardless of who is saying it Gabriel
says you're right a lot of too many men
are allies and Etc I think I'm picking
up what you're putting down I'm 43 and I
see the non-stop efforts to feminize
Society in general of course I
experienced it in the early days nothing
like it is today it is cause and effect
yeah and the thing is feminine women
agree with me typically typically even
women that these things apply to
generally if they're not completely
narcissistic they agree with me you
might be a perfectly pleasant person
person but that doesn't change the
general Trends but women are so
narcissistic that they can never think
outside of themselves and it's the most
frustrating thing it is the most
frustrating thing because you can never
make a point because the women are
always too busy talking about their
personal situations that you can never
even get to the point so I had a tweet I
said studies actually back up that
liberal men are more low testosterone
don't shoot the messenger if the shoe
fits and guys this is what you'll start
to notice is if they're freaking out and
getting mad think about it if I said
men that tend to disagree with me that
date nights are for women tend to be low
testosterone because they have the
feminine point of origin if you're a
jacked high testosterone guy it's not
going to offend you because it doesn't
apply and so what you'll see constantly
is the women are freaking out because it
applies and I don't care I don't give a
[__] if it applies to you or or not
truth is truth regardless of who's
saying it and who it applies to so there
was a guy that responded to this he said
testosterone is produced by struggle not
compliance who is more compliant than
liberal men that worship women exactly
exactly are the women now arguing that
men do not want sex silence and a
sandwich so then it's like this trend I
see they'll say well everybody wants sex
silence at a sandwich well then my
question is why are girls nights all
talking you know men men will like their
boys nights they'll be like sitting
around playing video games or like maybe
they're like playing a game or something
like we know it's not the same and
that's a default egalitarianism because
they're implying that we are the same
will men know what men want they just
rather play stupid and act like we're
complicated so they have excuses not to
better themselves it's their game yeah
and typically men that talk like this
are pandering to their wives they're
pandering guys that is the biggest red
pill when you realize how many men are
lying to you on a daily basis when you
figure out what is true in the world you
realize that all of these guys are lying
to you to spare your
feelings they don't men don't typically
tell you if you're saying something
stupid if you're doing something stupid
and they don't typically tell you when
you're wrong and so there's an entire
generation of women who we have never
been told no in our lives what you'll
see is women coping like this so I'm
going to reread this to show you the
response so do men wake up and think wow
I just wish I could have some more
quality time with my woman today no be
real they want sex silence and a
sandwich generally true or generally not
true and so what Samantha does is she
goes to attack me personally and my
followers personally my argument at its
core is men prefer sex silence at a
sandwich to quality time they don't
typically wake up thinking they want
quality time that's typically more of a
female thing and her response is to say
did all your bitter divorced followers
tell you that and my question for one I
would say the majority of my followers
have not been married as most young
people are not married in 2023 but what
if they are bitter and divorced what if
they are does it make what they're
saying untrue does it make the facts not
true and that's what you'll see when
women don't when they can't attack the
argument they attack my followers or
they attack me they failed at marriage
maybe listening to some happily married
men and my response to that is
where and so many times they want us to
look at their small communities and
think that it applies to everybody I am
sure there are some religious
homeschooled Amish
communities that are happily married but
again the exception doesn't make the
rule and and generally marriage has a
bad reputation today for a reason
regardless of how you feel about it it
doesn't matter your religion it doesn't
matter how you feel there is a reason
that the reputation is what it is today
and until women start accepting some
responsibility for that reputation
instead of pointing the finger at men
and saying you're a bitter in divorce we
will never see change because how can
you take accountability and change the
system if we can't even take
accountability for our part to play in
it women always blame the
men I'm not disputing that men want sex
and sandwiches who doesn't again that's
egalitarianism because she's implying
that men and women are the same they're
not the same but quality husbands so now
she's saying quality husbands also
genuinely enjoy quality time with their
wives so if you do the feminine thing
which is quality time date nights that's
more feminine then you're deemed a
quality husband and you see this trend
from tradcon are they a quality husband
a real man this is the common Trend and
it's a way to shame men into doing the
female behavior and it's a way for them
to control and I am tired of women
shaming men for being men there is
nothing wrong with men liking sex
silence and sandwiches there's nothing
wrong with date nights being about women
but why do we have to deny reality why
is this even a
conversation the fall is always shaming
all of your followers must be bitter
divorced at incels you don't blow up as
fast as I do without saying something
that resignates with most men why do
happily married women have such a need
to be right how is she finding a way to
argue with the fact that men prefer sex
silence and sandwiches not date
nights really and truly and I think
about this I'm like if you guys argue
like this with me on Twitter all day I
pray for your husbands because look and
I don't know I don't know I'd like to
say I don't actually know but women tend
to argue with me the way they argue with
their husbands and it kind of shows what
they do behind closed
doors Western culture and family value
says the dating Market is basically
guaranteed to create male loneliness and
sexlessness by Design that's how women
want it so shaming men for that is about
as low as it gets considering women
planned it by design by openly rejecting
the cultural idea of someone for
everyone women's started this mess and
how can we fix it if we can't even take
accountability for our part to play
Someone said not having date nights is
the quickest way to a sexless marriage
so okay let me get this straight your
husband's working 80 hours a week now
you're going to deprive him of sex when
he gets home so this is basically
telling men that they need to pay for
sex with you really do you hear how some
of you sound now Frank says date nights
with a spouse does not mean spending
hundreds of dollars Pearl a date night
can just be a walk through the park and
a cup of coffee okay let's go with a cup
of coffee who loves coffee
dates who is that for are the men lined
up to spend their days at Starbucks or
do the women line up to spend their days
at
Starbucks do men like to walk through
the park or do they like to play sports
at the park we are so confused that you
have men arguing against what men like
to do okay so again I didn't even know I
guess this guy is married to like a girl
that I was tweeting at I don't know who
he is so I'd like to say all I'm doing
is pointing out Trends another Trend
I've noticed is that the men that tend
to say things like this so again I
didn't insult him I said the men that
tend to say things like this their
default is egalitarianism meaning they
grew up typically with a domineering
mother or no dad and you can typically
pick out the domineering mother it's
usually by their career field so you
could look at like nurses tend to be
domineering um lawyers tend to be
domineering so you can kind of pick it
out these guys are usually low te the
reason I say this is because they
generally default to the women's point
of view then everybody starts freaking
out and saying I was insulting him no no
no no no no I was simply talking about a
trend but they canot take it personally
um Josh says women only demand nights
when their partner can't validate them
his attention isn't worth anything so
she squeezed him for all he has if he
actually had a solid boundaries and was
able to validate her she would be happy
just being around him yes women that are
grateful for a man's time and attention
do not have high demands with what he
does with that time and attention and no
it doesn't mean he doesn't love you or
isn't IND you it might just mean the man
is busy some men work like 80 hours a
week they don't have time David modder
said not true when you're with the right
person every day should be slightly
childish when it can be why wouldn't you
want to spend time with your best mate
laughing and again that's egalitarianism
is your husband supposed to be your best
friend no and has have relationships
improved since we started referring to
our husband as her best
friend again there's nothing wrong with
date nights my point is that when we
start arguing that men and women look at
them same and they're not generally for
women that's when we're starting to live
in delusion and just cater to women for
a lifetime and really these chicks
should thank me because I'm being honest
what we can learn from this date night
debate is that women feel entitled to
protection provisioning and date nights
on top of it men may hear this and think
that the juice just isn't worth the
squeeze I also see conservative women
defaulting to egalitarianism but men
like date nights too men and women are
different if men value date nights like
that then why aren't they complaining
about not going out just comment sense
can tell us this is more of a female
thing exactly if men really missed date
nights why aren't they complaining about
when they don't get them it's always the
women complaining patterns Never Lie we
do not give a [__] about date nights
once a month if something's interesting
or worthwhile okay but to put it in
context men care about date nights the
same way women care about men's sneaker
collections oh yeah so this is what
started the whole debacle this is what
started it I was asking how many times a
month is able to get a babysitter for a
wife and a mother until she's like a bad
mom I couldn't believe 57% said two
times a month I'm like
dang five nights in a month a quarter
wow I'm like wow okay well but you know
I'm happy for these polls because at
least they're honest uh at least we can
get honest responses this is how men
feel about it now you might argue they
might accept accept it that a woman is
gone more than that but this is what
they would prefer over half of men
Lauren Chan ways in husbands and wives
should make time for date nights and
time alone together even with young kids
weekly is ideal but not always feasible
and I really just thought to myself why
it's interesting and this is my point
see it's like they always get so
triggered it's I ask why it's
interesting to think of these things in
terms of the past I have a feeling the
women of 200 to 500 years ago were not
worried about date night and had bigger
things to worry about it seems like a
modern thing okay and then see do you
see the it's always the default Pearl
what do you mean why my husband is hot
and I want a loan time with him seems
pretty self-explanatory so again there's
two things my husband is hot I I didn't
ask I don't know what your husb I don't
know who you people's husbands are and I
want aone time with again so the default
is what does she want again it's not not
what he wants it's what she wants and
that's what most of these wives do they
think about what they want all day and
not what he wants because for whatever
reason us chicks are just really
self-centered okay so enough about the
tradcons today I'm also going to be
talking about Kim Kardashian is now the
cover for men of the year so obviously
Kim Kardashian is a very a very
accomplished entrepreneur like obviously
she really crushed the patriarchy and
really just worked hard for her place in
the world I mean it's really tough to
post selfies all day you know guys I've
posted a selfie or two a lot of work you
know you got to get the Angles and smile
I get it I I I think it it's totally
fair that she's paid more than like a
coal miner now obviously here we have
the Cheetos that she's licking off in
her pants suit now I think it's
especially ironic that she's wearing a
pants suit for this considering she
started her career naked I mean start
naked and naked you know what I
mean you know
like I mean a man of the year so you
know it's so funny though there was so
much outrage when a woman or there was
you know what's funny about this there's
never any outrage when women take a man
of the year when there is an award or a
group that is just for men when women
infiltrate it it is
celebrated but when men infiltrate and
take our Awards like Caitlyn Jenner did
and like eight years ago now it actually
is not celebrated it is shamed and there
is outcry why why why why Dale bot says
imagine the backlash to a man being
named Woman of the Year exactly so after
all the dicks she's finally growing her
own no my dream is to one day go to
America but nowadays I'm going to stay
in Europe come to the Balkans we deal
with this pronunciation and this gender
[__] try to bark or something stupid we
have places for anything and anyone guys
this is sad as women we cannot be men we
will never be men and the more we try to
be men the less happy we will become Kim
Kardashian will never be happy because
she did not do things in the natural way
women as they get older they get more
and more crazy we know this the natural
order of the world goes God men women
children women will never accomplish
what men accomplish ever we are weaker
vessels we are not built that way and it
doesn't matter how you feel about it it
doesn't matter how many of these
[__] fake Awards they give us we are
not men we will never be men and the
more we try to be men the less happy we
will be and men need to stop putting up
with it they need to stop enabling this
they need to stop giving us these free
handout jobs these free Awards if we
want to go after something fine work for
it but what I'm tired of is being given
minority and women Awards give something
to us because we are competent not
because we have a vagina between our
legs so one thing that we've talked
about on the show is that when women
make bad decisions it is celebrated
constantly and I see this all the time
if a woman is fat she's put on the cover
of a magazine Kim Kardashian became a
billionaire off of being a [__] women
are constantly rewarded for bad
decisions so we never see reality but
men on the other hand have to see the
truth that's that's why women we can't
get the same level of respect as men
because men have to go through 10 times
more things than women do in order to
get where we can get H in in order for a
woman to get on a yacht she just has to
be hot in order for a man to get on a
yacht he has to be somebody that is the
difference between men and women and I
saw a story where a man lost
weight after a friend texted him fat F
every day for six
weeks so this guy just called called him
fat for 6 weeks straight and this guy
lost all of his weight can you imagine
if that was a woman we would just go to
a room and cry or something Mike says
men and women are not the same that's a
good friend and I think this is also why
women will always be more lonely than
men by ourselves men have real genuine
true friendships that last a lifetime
women generally don't we go through
friends very quickly women generally
turn on each other women have a much
harder time having lifelong
relationships and it shows chosen
marriage I mean we quit everything you
think we're going to stick out we can we
we can't even stick out our husbands you
think we're going to stick out
friendships well have kids with the guy
and not stick that out um but again I
think it results in men having deeper
and more meaningful friendships than
women generally do Patriot dad says this
is how men communicate and should this
is a good friend who showed him he cared
by letting him know he was unhealthy and
needed to fix it you can't do this with
a woman they will get their feelings
hurt and hate you for it men need to be
told the truth and women do too and we
need to start learning how to take it
because this Society goes crazy when you
have to constantly lie to us Jada flame
says see dudes be straight up with their
friends and results happen girls lie to
their friends straight up I wanted to
talk about the modern mother today I've
talked a lot about this I have
interviewed over a thousand people on
the show and when you have interviewed
this many people you start to see
patterns and Trends in society and one
Trend that I have seen is the modern
mother now the modern mother looks like
a mother she has a ring like a mother
many times she is married like a mother
not always but a lot of times she is
married but she doesn't act like a
mother and there are so many older women
wives and mothers that give their
daughters terrible advice and compete
with their daughters I had a tweet that
said do women even like their kids
you would be amazed at how many mothers
compete with their own daughters I have
heard stories of mothers dressing
skimpily around daughters boyfriends I
have heard stories of mothers sleeping
with daughters boyfriend Trad cath HQ
says modern women want to get married
and have children but not be a wife and
a mother yes that is women that might on
paper be a wife and a mother but that
doesn't mean they act like one and it's
really obvious you can see it in their
life life decisions they usually have a
lot of work done they typically have big
hoop earrings are typically in the
latest fashion trends they're typically
at all of the socializing events because
they care more about themselves their
reputation and their looks more than
their children bonfire brother this is a
tragic Behavior I've noted in some women
as a father I want my children to do
better than me that means I will do a
good job and my legacy will survive no
they really don't you can tell in all
the truth treatment that's why they' be
wanting trophies for doing the bare
minimum for them and that's what's
expected and I noticed this too all of
these women want to be put on a pedestal
and treated like a God because they
stayed home with the kids it's actually
not a selfless job it's actually a
privilege it is absolutely a privilege
that you should be thanking your husband
for and you'll notice in women's
language when they're constantly
bringing the conversation towards them
so they'll say I stay home with the kids
I am a traditional woman when they're
bringing the attention to them typically
they're not traditional because
traditional women bring attention to the
family and their husband they are family
focused and husband first they do not
need the glory and so many times you see
modern mothers seeking validation and
attention from the world when they
should be seeking it from their husbands
that is why families do not work in this
dynamic because you cannot serve two
masters the public in your your husband
you should only be seeking validation
from God and from your husband and so
let me pull you guys up a clip from the
morning show let's pull it
up okay okay then I'll will leave great
go share it with America they'll take
care of you oh [__] you
kid [__]
you did you really just say that yeah I
did I just said [__]
you and I mean have [__] dare you you
after all that I have done and all that
I have given to you my life my love my
body I broke my [__] vagina with a
big [__] head of yours and I had to
be surgically tone back together I bet
you didn't know that did you oh and if
you just staying with your father after
all these years of him driving me insane
with his condescending my loves he
talked to me like I was a [__]
5-year-old and I am sick of it I am sick
sick of it I I I want happiness I earned
happiness I'm a human being
Lizzy and you know what else don't you
dare [__] at me about my career Little
Miss I'm so Progressive yes I worked my
ass off to get where I am and I wanted
it I wanted to be something I wanted to
remain something in this world I didn't
know that was a [__] crime life isn't
perfect okay baby we don't get
everything we want you're young you know
go make the life that you want you see
how [__] easy it is and stop bitching
and complaining and blaming
me and you get your own [__] Pizza
this is my pizza chcken my pizza I earn
this [__] [__] you Mom [__] you kid if
you could save
your you'd save us
all is that what you called
me okay so I wanted to point out a
couple things in this Dynamic this is
what I call the modern mother and The
Ungrateful daughter what did Jennifer
Aniston say in this clip she said I
deserve happiness she talks about how
her husband treated her like a
5-year-old with all of the my loves so
this is a woman that is married and
unhappy in the marriage and put her
career over the family and it leads to
children that are ungrateful often and
confused and a lot of times they adopt
this leftist wokeism because their
mother was not there to instill good
values and be a good example women like
this want all of the credit do you know
how much I did for you they don't do
anything nice out of kindness they do it
out of wanting gratitude and credit the
most selfless amazing mothers that you
know are not worried about credit
they're worried about you and so there
is an entire generation of moms that
don't do things out of the kindness of
their heart they do things out of
wanting validation from everybody and
you know they want to be God's gift to
the Earth because they gave birth yeah
we get it dogs give birth um now I'm not
saying you know at some point as an
adult you can't blame your parents
anymore I mean at some point you're an
adult whatever should happened you got
to just get over it but it's it's a
common Dynamic I see it's usually a
domineering mother and an ungrateful
daughter that results in it this Dynamic
is very very common in middle class
upper class families because it's
usually the mother that put the career
before the kids and often times you'll
see a bunch of liberal Kids come out of
there because the mother was not there
to instill values and properly influence
the kids um I saw another motherdaughter
video that I thought really showed this
Dynamic let's pull it up okay so I need
to know because what I just read was
pretty serious what happened on Fourth
of July um we started fighting um so she
came towards me um we were going back
and forth she was saying something like
I'll choke SL you I'll slap you because
she didn't like how I was talking to her
um but she was coming at me aggressive
so I gave her the same
energy um then she I remember she like
grabbed me by my neck and like pushed me
on the bed oh my gosh okay and then um
she grab by my neck pushed me on the bed
and then as I was like getting back up I
don't remember exactly how it led to it
but we started having like a Tuan War
like she pulled me by my hair and I
pulled her by her so like at this point
we're going like back and forth um I'm
telling her let me go um yes that
situation it made me like not want to do
with her got it did she throw things at
you that day too yeah so um she threw
like the one of the game boxes and they
hit me my
face is the first time you got physical
with your mom no no we just started
arguing recently probably like last year
is when we got in like the biggest
argument cuz usually like I'll just shut
down down I won't talk anymore got it oh
so your personality is you shut down so
do you feel like she threatens you is
that's what's making you shut down um
she threatens me when she feels like I'm
being combative like did she threaten
you that day yes you told my producers
that you said that your mother said
she's going to make you
leak your mother said to you you gonna
make you Le now listen I have friends in
the hood so I know what when they say
that what that mean right someone said
they're gonna make you leak what what
did you take it as when she said that um
that she's trying to like like she want
to fight me like I'm not her kid anymore
so when she was talking to me it was
like like what's up like I don't want to
be like that my mom but I'm sorry you
fine
yeah
yeah what was it like growing up with
your mom crazy yeah in what ways
um she had like abusive
relationships uh I had to intervene a
lot of times um
yeah I would be in the middle of it I'll
have to be like a mediator because it
was more like the person that she dealt
with at the time it was like he'll be
more guessing towards her than he was to
me so like okay well talk to him and see
make sure he doesn't come to house and
try to harm us or something um it was
really like I was put in situations I
don't want to be
in did your mom get into physical
utation with other people when you were
younger yes you did what happened when
she was 8 months pregnant with your
sister
um so that day she was going to
McDonald's um it wasn't that far she
asked me if I wanted to go with her and
that day I just didn't feel like it um
so cuz she didn't have her car that's
why she walked to McDonald's she SE I
guess she seen her car on the street she
seen her car on the street or she seen
the person that had her car on the
street she seen him and like she
confronted them and like per usual they
like was tling or whatever the girl she
ran her
over ran your brother over and she was
eight months pregnant mhm okay and so
how old were you at this time seven so
you're seven years old and your mother
gets ran over while pregnant um does did
did your siblings survive did not
survive okay okay so what dides she say
now when you bring it up get over it oh
okay what did your mom say when she
found out you were pregnant at 17 she
want me to abort it she wanted you to
abort it okay and what did you say back
um at first I was like okay like maybe
she's right maybe but then when it was
like time to go for I was like okay
don't want to do it yeah and your mother
is 38 and you're 21 so she had you at 17
so you had a child at 17 your mother had
a child at 17 okay understand what so
what do you want from me today what are
you hoping for um I want my mom to
understand what she put me through I
understand like you know we can move
past it but I want you to like not admit
but own up to what you put me through
like it's acknowledge it at least got it
got it got it okay that makes a lot of
sense to me um well listen it's time to
meet your mom so everyone please welcome
porsa to the
[Applause]
show so hello um so first of all I'm
just don't understand how me being ran
over caused her so much trauma to where
it's like she just can't get over it one
fact you weren't there that's a fact you
didn't see me getting run over I know I
didn't say that but you didn't see me
getting ran over you didn't like
experience that so I'm just saying so to
put yourself in that trauma and stay in
it it's something that I just can't do
por I want to know from you can you tell
me what happened on the 4th of July yeah
I you can take a seat please yeah please
take a seat thank you thanks for being
here by the way right yeah um so the 4th
of July um okay first of all I'm yelling
at my youngest daughter so if you see
I'm yelling at her I'm the mama you know
this a bear I'm I'm roaring right now so
I'm yelling and then I come in there and
I say something to you and I got an
attitude me if I was there I'm like girl
bye you talk at me you don't talk to me
no you're too sensitive no I'm not yes
you are I don't like that like I'm not
going to be on those no you don't know
how to you don't take what people say to
you and you don't be like okay well I
did this I'm sorry you don't know how to
apologize you be like okay well get over
it like oh
well why did it get physical that day
though I'm still not understanding why
they get physical because when she stood
up she was talking to Buck you know what
I mean don't get up and start bucking at
me say you would hit me like what juy I
did not tell you that that I would hit
you I yes you did you kept draining me
well guess what well get out of my face
then girl who thre the first punch that
day it wasn't no punches because she was
doing too much so yeah I choked her a
little bit yeah get down sit down so
this is what I call the ghetto mom the
ghetto mom the abusive mom um she's
constantly not apologizing for anything
she's constantly blaming her daughter
and she doesn't act like a mother that
actually loves her daughter why would
you tell a 17-year-old to abort their
kid how is the daughter going to turn
out to be a good person when she has no
guidance from the mother whenever she
has any complaints the mom just kind of
puts it back on her she's abusive poop
earrings heavy makeup again that
indicates self-centered and the saddest
thing is typically even Abus of mothers
the daughters still want relationships
with them the daughter even said she was
willing to move past this daughters
crave relationships with their mothers
and it's actually so sad how few mothers
act like wives and actual mothers and
can be that for their daughter so the
first one I call the modern mother the
second one I call the ghetto mother once
you start noticing this stuff guys you
can't unsee it the modern mother tends
to prioritize her career above the
family the ghetto mom tends to have more
like anger issues abusive usually like
the usually the modern mother's like
working or divorce once you start
noticing this guys most family
dysfunction comes from the mom um it's
usually her inability to follow what her
husband says and it's usually her
inability to listen and and her will to
control the man it's in the Bible they
you know they said that you would have
the will that you would want to control
your husband I can't remember the exact
verse but it's true guys two more
stories today so Megan rapo is a female
soccer player and i' I've spoken out
against Megan because I really think
she's just a crybaby that wants better
pay in sports I'm a female athlete I
play basketball volleyball I did it for
16 years okay um I understand why we
make less and I'm very grateful for men
for subsidizing women's leagues and
allowing me to play as long as I did I
think I learned to work hard I think it
made me learn how to accomplish goals I
think it kept me out of a lot of TR
trouble I am very grateful for athletics
in my life now there's pros and cons to
every decision but I'll say one thing it
had a lot of Pros it helped me get along
with people and made me more social and
I will never complain about pay even
though I could I had the opportunity to
go play professionally and I decided not
to because I didn't want to pursue the
pay even though I love playing life is
about choices and trade-offs some people
want to be an artist and make zero for a
lifetime you don't blame the customer
you blame the product so there is a
video of Megan disrespecting God so not
only does she want to mislead young
women that were oppressed somehow not
only does she want these special
treatment and privileges not only does
she complain about a league that is
subsidized by the men she also
disrespects God take a look yeah I
thought about a little bit I mean you
know I'm not a religious person or
anything and if there was a god like
this is proof that there isn't fued up
um so yeah it just it's just [__] up
you guys like minutes
in so bad yes no way so she had a career
ending injury and she's in her 30s I
want to say like mid-30s um how much
longer did you expect to play
chica you know I would be grateful that
you weren't injured so far and you got
to take your career to such a high level
you know I've never been that seriously
injured I've had like small problems
here and there and I'm really grateful
that my career the majority was
relatively injury-free she wants to
disrespect God and say this is proof
that he doesn't exist because I I was
injured maybe you just stepped on your
foot wrong chica um and I don't
understand why non-religious people
can't just be respectful of religious
people you don't have to believe what
they believe but why do you have to go
out of your way to disrespect them it's
the same thing I saw a nun Halloween
costume it was like [__] why just Le
let the religious people be religious so
the com comment section was cooking her
she says she represents everything wrong
with our society now and her fall from
pride is proof that God does exist yes
yeah that woman is so prideful last
story of the day Twitter is erupting
right now Twitter is erupting guys I
couldn't believe this happened Ben
Shapiro and Candace Owens are literally
going at it on Twitter on Twitter as you
guys know I have been following Ben
Shapiro and Candace Owens so Candace
Owens has has been outspoken that she
does not believe in genocide now when it
comes to the Middle East or the Israel
situation I'm not an expert that is not
my my field but Candice had a tweet
saying that she believed that it was
wrong what Israel when Israel bombed
Palestine Ben Shapiro comes out and says
her behavior is Despicable at a private
event there was a clip of Ben saying
that he thought Candace owens's Behavior
was Despicable I don't know if he
thought he was being recorded maybe he
didn't but this clip starts circulating
on YouTube now Candace Owen weighs in on
this clip on Tucker Carlson let's go so
I can't respond to it on a level of
intellect because there there's nothing
that he has expressed in that at least
in that short clip that he fundamentally
disagrees with in terms of what I said
but I will say that I'm not going to
respond with the same aded hinant
attacks I don't think it helps further
discussion and it if that was me that
was caught on a video saying that about
colleagues that I work with I would be
embarrassed I would so I think that the
video speaks more to Ben's character
than it speaks to mine has he texted you
to apologize or explain or anything no
what tends to happen is of course we we
all have elements of selfishness within
us and so when it particularly pertains
to an issue that impacts you Candace
Owens is obviously upset as anyone would
be that Ben Shapiro is coming after her
you know she does this thing and I and I
have to be honest guys women do use
religion as a way to like kind of be
passive aggressive we to like we we do
that we do that and she does a tweet
which is clearly about her previous
tweet condemning genocide blessed are
the peacemakers for they shall be called
the children of God blessed are they who
are persecuted for righteousness' sake
for theirs is the Kingdom of Heaven
blessed are you where men shall revile
you and persecute you and say all manner
of evil against you falsely for my
name's sake no one can serve two masters
either you will hate the one and love
the other or you will be devoted to one
despise the other you cannot serve both
God and money so Ben Shapiro comes in
and says if Candice if you feel that
taking money from the daily wire somehow
comes between you and God by all means
quit I'm like
what this public Feud this public Feud I
never thought I would be in a world
where political commentators are
publicly like quitting and getting F I
mean no one's quit yet but I mean I
can't imagine this goes in a different
direction Candace says you have been
acting unprofessional and emotionally
unhinged for weeks now we all have to
sit back and allow it and have to
exercise exceeding understanding for
your raw emotion you are utterly out of
line for suggesting that I cannot quote
Biblical scripture the Bible is not
about you yeah okay I gotta be honest
though
Candice
Candice I think I I think it could be
inferred that she was implying but at
the same time I I think I would have
just ignored it if I was Ben I I don't
think it was worth responding to um I am
genuinely confused why asking questions
and quoting Bible verses about peace
warrants to call a resign from the daily
wire there should be more room in the
conservative movement for disagreement
we can do better than this yeah and I
don't know what it is about this issue
this issue like I've seen it like tear
apart professional relationships in
front of our eyes when it's like why
can't we just talk freely and explore
both sides but you can't even do that
without getting demonetized on YouTube
guys I don't know I'm not saying this is
the reason but I am saying it's
interesting timing um okay but let me
know whose side you are on Ben Shapiro
or Candace Owens I am a fan of both of
them I think they're both awesome um so
it's unfortunate to see them fighting
like this but very entertaining last
video the top comment was also I've only
ever been attacked by women and one of
our Urban youths it seems women aren't
held to the same standards and we are
starting to see the results yeah yeah
you're telling me
guys please please please make sure you
like your favorite comment in the
description and please please sign up
for our email list um I mean that's the
only thing we can really do right now is
try to figure out alternative platforms
and ways that we can keep the channeled
going so it would really mean a lot to
me if you guys could buy a t-shirt that
women shouldn't vote um we're going to
be dropping more t-shirts in the next
couple of weeks that you could support
the channel also please please please
sign up for the email list it is free um
that way you can stay connected with us
and we're going to have a new website
coming in the next couple of weeks so
please please please like the video guys
subscribe and I'll talk to you next time